tél
en attendant ses soeurs comme ça pour se
mettre en forme est en train qu'est ce
que tu préfères dostoïevski zulawski oui
oui ce qu'ils imaginent mal ange tu sois
comme ce pauvre jeudi la type qui a
écrit les versets sataniques été
condamné à mort par l'imam comme unis il
a dit que tu aies pu dire tous les
musulmans du monde tu cherches tu
imagines tu voi tableau et tu décides de
te faire refaire le visage qui serait
dommage quand on doit aller au foot le
dire est ce que tu te faudrait refaire
le visage comme denise fabre comme
evelyne leclerc ou comme marie-france
cuba là je suscitais personnes 15h30 sur
marco ladant de nice voudrait ressembler
à donner maintenant les nouvelles qu'il
ferait plus plaisir à la radio est
maintenant entre éveillant la fin de
l'apartheid ou la mort de pinochet
si tf1 a supprimé le juste prix tout ça
je te comprends alors maintenant tu es
dans un ascenseur s'est coincé avec qui
tu préférais être coincé dans
l'ascenseur avec joie et des ralliés
bernard henri lévy mme philippe soler
bernard henri lévy tu peux être coincé à
cause des cheveux du thor va lui faire
plaisir
alors ce que tu reproches le plus à dieu
d'avoir mis sur terre les impuissants
les homosexuels les choses on y va
doucement les années sans ta rien contre
les chevaux des accords alors maintenant
je sors un soir dans une boîte même
c'est pas très mondaine et pitcho
rencontre un mec génial vraiment
s'étudie saliès et je craque c'est le
coup de foudre
tu rentres avec lui et tarifs chez toi
et tu as oublié un truc sur la table de
nuit qu'est ce que ces kits en mer
devraient le plus vis-à-vis de ce mec
que tu veux absolument séduire bien
entendu ce serait d'avoir oublié un
godemichet ou mannequin je te comprends
alors maintenant tu es obligé c'est un
jeu un peu obligé de faire l'amour
oblige on a été obligé d'un flingue sur
la tempe je viens tu es obligé était
prisonnière
tu es obligé de faire l'amour est-ce que
tu préférais faire l'amour avec carlos
je suis gâté car lauzon portillon les
proportions catherine lara ou zaza le
cheikh de michel drucker te fâche pas de
rigueur de ta maison disent que te
pardonnera jamais de refuser le chien
drucker alors gaza j'avais turinois
souriant ça va faire plaisir à nous
c'est vrai
il va être très content encore
maintenant ton petit ami d'un petit ami
il a imaginé il ya des problèmes dont il
ait pas trop hein ça peut arriver sur ça
arrive à tout le monde alors qu'est ce
que tu fais tu discutes en lui disant
comment elle s'appelle une trompe je
suis sûr qu'elle a eu notre première
solution
deuxième solution tu le ferais un truc
spécial troisième solution de tout cas
ce qu as tu te casser du espérons que ce
soit parce d'hazard irait très très mal
bon alors tu rencontres un mec le mec
génial de tout à l'heure la tv oublié là
n'ont jamais oublié le godemiché sur la
tenue alors le mec il est super mais il
a un problème il a le hoquet
il parle sans arrêt où il est très
cochon qu'est ce que ces kits emmerde le
moi le hockey
ils arrêtent pas parler aux lys
insupportable par le lycée mais qui dit
tu me plais toi bon alors il a le hoquet
il parle sans arrêt ou à temps il est
très très cochon
qu'est ce que tu préfères non moi c'est
drôle c'est drôle alors maintenant
imagine que tu achètes un perroquet
c'est cet apéro tapas perroquet pour
tâche est un perroquet à zhuhai tout est
dit
tout a plane crash sa sublime perroquet
qu'à prendre tout ce qu'on lui dit une
phrase si l'argent est ce que tu
préfères l'ua pour quelle phrase tu veux
apprendre
est ce que tu vas prendre l usine a
oublié de fermer le gaz ce qui est
important est ce que tu veux apprendre
et est ce que le mec a mis sa capote ou
est ce que tu vas prendre ikoko arrête
là coco cocoon corps